let's talk more about trade politics and
the other stories of the day senior
political analyst Brit Hume is here
tonight could even breath my breath you
know just before we came out here the
president tweeted about this story
surprised that Harley Davidson of all
companies would be the first to wave the
white flag I fought hard for them and
ultimately they will not pay tariffs
selling into the EU European Union which
has hurt us badly on trade down 151
billion dollars taxes just a Harley
excuse be patient hashtag Magath
thoughts on that well I would interpret
be patient to me and just let this go
for a while harley-davidson don't don't
do anything because I think I'll get a
deal out of this
and everybody will be happy so far we
haven't seen any deals it's not even
really clear breath how much I'm you
know what negotiations are under way so
I can understand the president's desire
to tamp this down because it you know
it's it's an embarrassing result but on
the big picture
you know when you look at this policy
and what they're attempting to do
potentially does it pay off down the
road this is this is the issue that has
bedeviled trading nations for
practically as long as there been such
things which is in nations and gated in
fair trade practices tariffs themselves
can be unfair trade practices china
engages in a range of practices designed
to advantage their companies in their
economy and disadvantage others it's not
fair and we have a set of rules to be
enforced by the World Trade Organization
I think the Trump administration is
basically concluded that that system
involving the World Trade Organization
is dysfunctional it doesn't work it
takes too long as too bureaucratic in
some cases stacked against the United
States which leaves you with what other
weapon in hand tariffs so in a sense you
end up fighting unfair trade practices
with tariffs now taps can be effective
and they do make a difference as the
Harley Davidson episode shows but they
are dangerous and if you trigger a trade
war and when she goes tip for tat and
tit for tat pretty soon you
you've got a bigger than nation
situation going on like what we had
during the Depression and everybody
loses and that's the danger the the
President may get deals out of this and
it may work but make no mistake about it
he's playing with fire yeah and it's the
be patient part that is hard work I want
to ask you about the civility story you
heard congresswoman Maxine Waters
in this news conference kind of walking
back her statements but not fully to
confront from cabinet members get in
their face after the Sarah Sanders
incident over the weekend a couple of
thoughts I don't think it's gonna play
that stuff is gonna play well with the
public at large no matter what your
political affiliation but it does
exemplify the extremes to which people
are going and the extremes which people
are feeling in reaction to this
president I'm not saying it's his fault
but what I am saying though is that
people are responding to him in the most
extraordinary way and every time he does
or says something what happens is that
it the the extrapolating from his
sometimes not very clear language people
take the most extreme conclusions about
what he's doing or trying to do and
react to them accordingly and the next
thing you know you're in a spiral of
uncivil but uncivil in civil behavior
like we're seeing here I don't think
it'll play very well I don't know what
Maxine Waters was talking about when she
said she never called for harm throwing
people out of restaurants and hounding
them in their homes is harmful it isn't
physical harm but it's harm nonetheless
I don't think I think it'll I think
she'll be quieted by her colleagues and
obviously the president has long history
of being a counter-puncher when he's
when he's all kinds of stuff to eat it
out you better you might be not happy
with what you ask for whatever he says
he's immediately taken as a veiled
threat right threat to do what not clear
but it's a wonderful so here comes the
cycle all over again
you know he's issuing threats I mean
it's just you know we need it we need to
stop all this and begin to behave in a
civilized manner and it's you know this
is the age we live and I'm afraid Brett
all right Brett thank you vet